[موسيقى]
هو
ربي اعطاك الم
فهل اتيت زكاه علمي
نقدر ناخذ هذه العلوم والمهارات اللي
اعطاك اياه تخدم بها الاخرين
الامر ما يتطلب مشاريع عظيمه
يتطلب بس حس كيف اترك اثر في حيات الناس
من افضل
الديره الا بسواع بجهودكم بمبادراتي
المجتمع الحيوي ما يتحقق اللي فيكم
مثل ما قلنا الامر لا يتطلب اي مناصب
والالقاب ولا حتى يتطلب شهاده دراسيه في
مدينه القديمه
في انسانه اسمها مدرسه
تعلمت سيدات شقرا القران على يدها
لا تمتلكها
كان لديها رساله
ويجيل امي ويجيل جداتنا كلهم في شجره
تعلموا القران على هذه السيده الله يغفر
لها ويكتب لها العلم
العلم النافع الذي يصلك اكثر في يوم الدين
بالنسبه لي انا شخصيا كانت رسالتي تربويه
ودخلتها بالصدفه معكم تناوله
تخصصي رياضه الاطفال
بدات عملي معلمه
والحمد لله كتب الله لي
اكمال دراسته العليا ماجستير الدكتوراه
برضو لمكان عملي معلمتي
الاطفال
ان شاء الله لي ان انتقل الى جامعه الملك
سعود كانا جامعيه
وكانت هذه اللحظه او
النقطه المفصليه في حياتي نقطه او لحظه
التغيير
بعمله
كرياض الاطفال كنت اقدم دورات تربويه
للامهات احيانا لاننا كانت رساله كانت قصه
اثناء عملي مع الامهات
بدي تحس باحتيال
ودوره ورا دوره ولا دوره بدي تكتشف ان
المشكلات
متكرره نفسها نفس المشكلات التربويه
متكرره
فكنت اقدم الارشاد هنا ارشاد هنا ارشادنا
ولاني في الميدان
اداره بفضل من الله
اوظف الاساليب اللي انا اعرفها فعاله
فتحت حساب بتويتر من عشر سنوات
وبرضو كانت هذه لحظه تغير
للامانه ما كانت الا الان انا ما عندي
رساله ولا صبر تفكر
ما ادركت
ان انا ملزومه بهذا الشيء
فتح حساب تويتر وبدينا نغرق انا من رياض
الاطفال رياض الاطفال والطفوله
شهر شهر سنه
بدا يزداد المتابعين
راحت وعلى فكره فتحت شيء ثاني اللي انتم
تعرفون
ومع ذلك
الى الان ما بدات
اسمع كلمات
مرحبا
لما يقولون
قالت
خوفتني هالشيء
وعلى اسامه وعلى عيالهم تعرفون مخي انك
تعرف ان كل مره غلط منك
تنتظر طفل الاطفال
وهدرك حينها ان الكلمات لا تنقد الدافع
والتغريده ما تكتب اي كلام
ممكن التغريد اللي تشوفونها تلاقي الصوره
يكون قاعده فيها ربع ساعه
اكثر اكتب وامسح واكتب وامسح ليش
اقرا ما بين
الصوص بس
الصوت غلط هل ممكن اولها احد بشكل من
الاشكال
وتذكرت بداياتي لما كانت الدعوه
[موسيقى]
ونحط هاشتاق اف اف فلو شهر كانت حاجه
بسيطه
مع السنوات
الكاس لما ازدادت
الرقعه اللي تشوف
وها فيه منقوعه 37 دوله انا ملايين
متابعين
زاد
المسؤول مسؤوليه
كلمه المستقيم سهله الناس
ترجع لكلامك في توجيهاتك افكارك
ويعتمدون عليها في
لذا
نفس الرساله الحين صارت رساله على فكره
بعد سنوات انها رساله كيف صارت
صار في حرص مني على اني ما اقطع تويتر
يعني على مدى عشر سنوات ما انقطعت الا
يمكن
اسبوع واحد
كاس نستمر له اربع سنوات 150
لانه
ما تملك عليك ويعني
مخيفه
كنت اتمنى رساله
للرفع الوعي الوالدي ورفع جوده التربويه
تحسين
حياتك ثم
انتم ايها الشباب
طلعتوا 30% من متابع
يني هذا مما كانت
شباب وشابات لا تزوجوا العيال
وهذا اللي
زاد من المسؤوليه صرت بدال
ما رفع من جثه الحياه الاسريه بالرشاد
الوالدي
ترى انه في اعداد
الابوين في الحياه الزوجيه
صحيح انه يطلع لي واحده واحده تقول انا
حرمت الخلفه بسببك لكن ايضا هناك من يرى
الان
وتعاملهم مع اطفال الاسره
فهذه ايضا زادت من المسؤوليه التي
[موسيقى]
اشعرت
فدخل عام الفكره لما حللنا الاساليب لدينا
عامل كوميديه هو اللي جابكم
فخلي الواحد يقول ايش هو عامل ناجح عامل
جاد فلنحافظ عليه
طبعا
كمستمعين الان تقدرون
نايس
مسلي العمل حقيقه
الضرب لابد مكان فيه شاف
اللي انا واجهني هو لاني انا اخترت مجالي
ظهوري اعلامي سواء كانت برامج تواصل
اجتماعي او كانت مليئه
فتعرضت للفجر
يهاجموني على اشياء
ما تحسب احساسك احيانا تحسب احنا لا
اعتقد كلكم شفتوا المقطع اللي فيه ماما
هذاك المقطع قسم الناس
نتكلم على الضد معظم الذين
عابوا المق
طع اكاديميين حملت الدكتوراه فقالوا
الاسلوب هذا ما يليق بدكتوره
كاني
اما
وبعضهم اكاديميين قالوا الرساله وصلت
والمعلقه
نعم اذا تريد تصير صاحب رساله تربويه
وهميه هل اوصل المعنى ان لابد ان اقوم
بتمثيل دور الطفل
هل ممكن نقول ما يسمح اني اسرع
يمكن وبالتالي
كان لابد اني امثل هذا الدار
وعارف الهجوم اللي بيجيني على
في حاجات
لازم نفكر فيها هل هي الرساله ام الذات
كمهاجمين
مسوا طعنونه في دين طعنوني في اخلاقي
وطعنوني في اممتي
حكام ممكن بكل سهوله اقول خلاص
انا الكلام خاصه ان نظرا للست خلاص مقاعد
خليني ارتاح
وبعدين
تجيني وحده مثل شهد السويد اليوم وقفتني
قالت انت على
وقعدت
سبحان الله
[موسيقى]
الماضيه الكثير
تغنيات رسائل
[موسيقى]
مو كانت المشكله وانا الان مستمتعه
ومرتاحه وشكله من كذا
اكثر من كذا
الا انها نكون يدفي راحه الامهات والاباء
واستمتاعهم
[موسيقى]
ولا فضل لي بالك
اللي بيعمل رساله يخدم وانا خادمتها
[موسيقى]
هو
هو زكاه العلم
واذا هذا البلد الحبيب اعطانا وعلمنا
واستكثرنا عليه
يحل لي ناس شعبه لا خير فينا ولا
[موسيقى]
معنى من كرسوا حياتهم
من
الاطفال وهي من قامات الدوله في الطفل
جهودها وعمل اكل سنه في مجال القياده في
رياض الاطفال في وزاره
في السعوديه
وطاعه ان توصل
المملكه
وتحافظ على مكانتها كدوله متصدره في الدول
العربيه في الرياضه الاطفال فبارك الله
معنا سميره العتيبي وين انت يا سميره
سميره العتيبي
صخرت حياتها وعملها وجهودها ودوراتها
لتمكين المكفوفين
من خلال الدورات التغريدات والجهود التي
تبذلها
ومن خلال نفسها كقدوه في المجال الرياضه
المهني والتعليم
عندي قدوه لهم وعلى يدك تتحسن حياتهم
فهمتي فتحين تبارك الله
سؤالي لكم هو
ما رساله انت وانت في الحياه
صبعك
ما يكون شيء عظيم كبير
ابسط جهد قد يكون رسالها اللهم اخلص النيه
ونواصل مهما واجهنا من
واختم بطلب ان كنت تؤمن بانك قادر ولديك
امكانيات وطاقات وعلم ومعرفه وبتخدم هذا
البلد وترابه وناسه
فسمعوني اعلى تحيه
[تصفيق]